je déclare sincèrement que je remplirai
mais de voir si j'ai décidé de faire la
politique c'est pour retourner redonner
au québec ce que québec m'a permis de
venir quand il est arrivé au québec à
l'âge de 18 ans sam hamad n'avait rien
il sait bien au comptoir de la st
vincent de paul pour la première fois
depuis le début de la guerre il accepte
de parler publiquement de sa syrie
natale
ça fait cinq ans maintenant que les
écoles sont fermées
les enfants vont plus à l'école on va
perdre une génération de jeunes
on vient de détruire le pays pour
longtemps très longtemps et ça ça ça
fait mal ça fait mal de voir des écoles
bombardé de voir les enfants / la
religion alors que leurs parents ont
étudié ensemble dans ma classe il y
avait des juifs des musulmans des
chrétiens est juste les critiques on
perd on était trente deux sortes de
critiques y avait pas la différence qui
était alimenté beaucoup plus tard on dit
même que bachar al-assad a fréquenté
cette école et qui s'est conclu le monde
absolu créateur était très simple ils
étaient plus jeunes que moi à plusieurs
années c'était respectueuse tessin pain
jeunes enfants qui étaient à l'école
sans bruit
bachar al assad préféré aller à l'école
en mobylette plutôt qu'avec le chauffeur
du papa dictateur le ministre québécois
n'approuve pas le régime d'al assad
mais il souligne que l'armée syrienne
protège les quartiers et les villages
chrétiens contre les islamistes
pour sam hamad le plus grand danger
vient du groupe armé état islamique qu
on devrait attaquer plus sérieusement
selon lui je peux pas croire
qu'aujourd'hui avec toute la technologie
toute la force militaire laveran
sainement et on devrait faire beaucoup
plus d'efforts
le ministre souhaiterait aussi plus
d'efforts sur le front des réfugiés lui
même fera sa part c'est pas tous des
terrasses et des bandits sont comme nous
et tout ce qu'ils cherchent l'espoir
j'ai commencé à faire les démarches pour
accueillir des familles et je veux
travailler avec les jce la bombe dans la
région de québec qu'on a un clan qui
sent bien cette semaine sa mimine avec
moi on a beaucoup parlé mais je n'aime
pas loin par mois de la syrie le maire
dit que ces citoyens sont prêts à ouvrir
grand leurs bras ou réfugiés de la main
sur la fable urbaine qui n'est pas parce
qu'on rend pas le français à saint-ouen
pour simple qu'on est d'obédience julio
qui la tient bon et tout ce blanc qu'on
veut pour savoir déjà d'ailleurs bien au
contraire actionnant la la poussée de
comment dire de générosité est
incroyable
le maire veut faire les choses en grand
pour accueillir jusqu'à 200 réfugiés
quand je vais mettre sur le téléphone je
veux dire aux gens d'affaires j'ai
besoin si j'ai besoin de ça je dis aux
ateliers j'ai besoin de temps celle qui
nourrit pas de nouveautés on est une
grande communauté ici mais en et ses
séries quand je me tue le téléphone ça
va marcher je crois ont accusé me kern
c'est une crise exceptionnelle ça prend
des mesures exceptionnelles
on peut pas comme en politique comme
personne politique se cacher derrière la
bureaucratie pour jussiê des retards ci
n'accepte à québec souhaite qu'ottawa
accélère les missions des visas pour les
syriens comme ce fut le cas après le
séisme en haïti ici sophie langlois
radio canada québec